This lecture is about the Word
Association mining and analysis.
In this lecture we're going to talk
about how to mine associations of words
from text.
This is an example of knowledge about
natural language that we can mine
from text data.
Here's the outline.
We are gooing to first talk about what is
word Association and then
explain why discovering such
relations is useful and finally we are
going to talk about some general
ideas about how to mine word
associations. In general
there are two word relations, and
these are quite basic.
One is called a paradigmatic
relation, the other is syntagmatic
relations.
A&B have paradigmatic relation if they
can be substituted for each other.
That means,
the two words that have paradigmatic
relation would be in the same semantic
class or syntactic class, and we can in
general replace one by the other
without affecting the understanding of
the sentence.
That means we would still have a valid
sentence. For example, cat and dog.
And these two words have
paradigmatic relation because
they are in the same class
of animal.
And in general, if we replace cat with
dog in a sentence, the sentence would
still be a valid sentence that you can
make sense of.
Similarly, Monday and Tuesday have
paradigmatic relation.
The second kind of relation is called
syntagmatic relation.
In this case, the two words that have
this relation can be combined with each
other.
So A&B have syntagmatic relation
If they can be combined with each other
in a sentence.
That means these two words are
semantically related.
So for example, Cat and sit are related
because a cat can sit somewhere.
Similarly, car and drive are related
semantically, and they can be combined
with each other to convey meaning.
However, in general we cannot replace
cat with sit in a sentence or car with
drive in a sentence to still get a
valid sentence.
Meaning that if we do that, the
sentence will become somewhat
meaningless.
So this is different from paradigmatic
relation and these two relations are
in fact so fundamental, that they
can be generalized to capture basic
relations between units in arbitrary
sequences.
And definitely they can be generalized to
describe relations of any items in the
language.
So A&B don't have to be words and they
can be phrases example.
And they can even be more complex
phrases
than just a noun phrase.
If you think about the general problem
of the sequence mining, then we can
think about the units in the sequence
data, and then we think of paradigmatic
relation as relations that are applied to
units that tend to occur in similar
locations in a sentence or in
a sequence of data elements in
general.
So they occur in similar locations
relative to the neighbors
in the sequence.
Syntagmatic relation on the other
hand, is related to co-occurring
elements that tend to show up in the
same sequence.
So these two are complementary
and basically relations of words, and
we're interested in discovering them
automatically from text data.
Discovering such world relations has
many applications.
First, such relations can be directly
useful for improving accuracy of
many NLP tasks, and this is
because this is part of our knowledge
about the language.
So if you know these two words or
synonyms, for example, and then you can
help a lot of tasks.
And grammar learning can be also done by
using such techniques because
If we can learn paradigmatic relations,
then we form classes of words.
Syntactic classes for example.
And if we learn syntagmatic
relations, then we would be able to
know the rules for putting together a
larger expression based on component
expressions.
So we'll learn the structure and what
can go with what else.
Word relations can be also very useful
for many applications in text retrieval
and mining.
For example, in search in text
retrieval we can use word associations
to modify a query.
And this can be used to introduce
additional related words to a query to
make the query more effective.
It's often called query expansion.
Or you can use related words to
suggest related queries to the user
to explore the information space.
Another application is to use word
associations to automatically construct
the topic map for browsing where we
can have words as nodes
and associations as edge. The user
could navigate from one word to
another to find information in the
information space.
Finally, such word associations can also
be used to compare and summarize
opinions.
For example, we might be interested in
understanding positive and negative
opinions about iPhone 6.
In order to do that, we can look at
what words are most strongly associated
with a feature word
like the battery in positive
versus negative reviews.
Such a syntagmatic relations would help
us show the detailed opinions about the
product.
So how can we discover such
associations automatically?
Now,
here are some intuitions about how to
do that.
Let's first look at the paradigmatic
relation.
Here we essentially can take advantage
of similar context.
So here you see some simple sentences
about cat and dog.
You can see they generally occur in
similar context.
And that, after all, is the definition
of paradigmatic relation.
So on the right side you can see I
extracted explicitly the context of cat
and dog from this small sample of text
data.
So I have taken away cat and dog from
the corresponding sentences so that you
can see just the context.
Now of course we can have different
perspectives to look at the context.
For example, we can look at the what
words occur in the left part of this
context.
So we can call this left context. What
words occur before we see cat, cat or
dog.
So you can see in this case clearly dog
and cat have similar left context.
You generally say his cat or my cat, and
you say also my dog and his dog. So
that makes them similar in the left
context.
Similarly, if you look at the words
that occur after cat and dog, which we
can call right context and they also
very similar in this case, of course
it's extreme case where you only see
eats and
In general you will see many other
words.
Of course that can follow cat and dog.
You can also even look at the general
context.
And that might improve the all words in
the sentence or in sentences around
this word.
And even in the general context you also
see some similarity between the two
words.
So this is just suggesting that we can
discover paradigmatic relation by
looking at the similarity of context of
words.
So for example, if we think about the
following questions, how similar are
context of cat and context of dog?
In contrast, how similar are context of
cat and context of computer?
Now intuitively, with imagine the
context of Cat and context of dog would
be more similar than the
context of cat and context of
computer, that means the first in the
first case, the similarity value would
be high.
Between the context of cat and dog,
whereas in the second the similarity
between contexts of cat and computer
would be low because they are
not having paradigmatic
relationship.
And then imagine what words occur after
computer.
In general they will be very different
from what words occur after cat.
So this is the basic idea of
discovering paradigmatic relation.
What about the syntagmatic relation?
Here we we are going to explore the
correlated occurrences again based on
the definition of syntagmatic relation.
Here you see the same sample of text.
But here we are interested in knowing
what other words are correlated with
the verb eats.
And what words can go with eat?
And if you look at the right side of
the slide and you will see I've taken away
the two words around eats.
I've taken away the word to its left and
also the world to its right,
In each sentence.
And then we can ask the question what
words tend to occur to the left of eat
and what words tend to occur to the
right of eat?
Now thinking about this question would
help us discover Syntagmatic relations.
Because syntagmatic relation
essentially captures such correlations.
So the important question to ask
for syntagmatic relation is whenever
eats occurs,
what other words also tend to occur?
So the question here has to do with
whether there are some other words that
tend to co-occur together with eats,
meaning that whenever you see eat, you
tend to see the other words.
And if you don't see eat, probably you
don't see other words often either.
So this intuition can help us discover
syntagmatic relations.
Now again, consider example-
How helpful is the occurrence of eats
for predicting occurrence of meat?
knowing whether eats occurs in a
sentence would generally help us predict
the
Whether meat also occurs indeed as if
we will see eats occur in a sentence,
and that should increase the chance
that meat will also occur.
In contrast, if you look at the
question in the bottom, how helpful is
occurrence of eats for predicting the
occurrence of text?
Because eats and text are not really
related, so knowing whether eats occurred
in a sentence doesn't really help us
predict
whether text also occurs in the
sentence.
So this is in contrast to the question
about eats and meat.
This also helps explain the intuition
behind the methods for discovering
syntagmatic relation.
Mainly we need to capture the
correlation between the occurrences of
two words.
So to summarize, the general ideas for
discovering word associations are the
following.
For paradigmatically relation we
represent each word by its context,
and then compute the context
similarity.
We are gonna assume the words that have high
context similarity to have paradigmatic
relation.
For syntagmatic relation, we will
count how many times two words occur
together in a context which can be a
sentence, paragraph or a document
even.
And we're going to compare their Co
occurrences with their individual
occurrences.
We're going to assume words with high
co-occurrences, but relatively low
individual occurrences to have
syntagmatic relations because they tend
to occur together, and they don't
usually occur alone.
Note that the paradigmatic relation
and syntagmatic relation, are actually
closely related.
In that paradigmatically related words
tend to have syntagmatic relation with
the same word that
they tend to be associated with the
same word, and that suggests that we
can also do join the discovery of the
two relations.
So these general ideas can be
implemented in many different ways, and
the course won't cover all of them, but
we will cover at least some of the
methods that effective for discovering
these relations.